good morning I'm Jim roar I'm your brief
host actually the introducer this
morning and also a member of the
Carnegie Mellon Board of Trustees I'm
also the chairman and CEO of PNC
Financial here in Pittsburgh and I think
I'm very very excited to be able to
welcome you at this conference I think
it's very interesting that we have a
conference called renewing globalization
and economic growth in a post-crisis
world you know we're in a crisis right
now it appears fortunately that we're
coming out of it a little bit but this
conference whether it's the g20 of this
conference that we're here talking about
today really talks about partnerships in
a globalized world rather than the
segments that we've lived in in the past
and I think all of us know that when we
work together we're able to do things
that surprised us actually we're able to
accomplish a great deal more than we
might have in the past working
independently when I think a Pittsburgh
I think that's exactly why the g20 is
here I've been here for a long time not
as long as ambassador Rudy but not very
many people have been so you know I but
when I think back in the 80s we lost a
quarter of a million steel related jobs
and it was a disaster for the city and
unemployment what rocketing up and we
lost some population 30 years later we
now sit here 25 years later we sit here
with a seven percent unemployment rate
to full percentage points below the
national average last August we had the
highest employment we ever had in the
history of the region and on two
occasions in the last seven years we've
been named the most livable city in the
United States we have arguably the best
cultural district we have the best
football team we have the best baseball
park
we have the best hockey team we have the
shortest commute according to Sunday
magazine we have the best view that
comes off of Mount Washington the entire
United States we have arguably the best
health care system in the world here in
our region and it's because people came
together and work together in a way that
they hadn't before they took the
opportunity to work together and build a
region that was totally different than
it was in the past we lost the industry
that drove us but I will tell you that I
can think back in not too long ago where
the Carnegie Mellon University and the
University of Pittsburgh didn't speak
they were complicated we're in
competition with each other for students
reputation for money every single facet
of their organization didn't work
together it totally changed we think
about Jerry Cohen and Martin Nordenberg
and how they have come together to
create the university center here that
is greater than it was in the past you
think of UPMC in the way it's worked in
the region it's different than it was in
the past and the way UPMC works with
Carnegie Mellon you can take the
Foundation's the corporation's the
financial service center our PNC's
delightfulness in hiring CMU students
you think about the the quantitative
math programs they put together it's the
way people have worked together that has
made the region so much better than it
has been in the past at CMU is a very
very big part of that our next step in a
global world is what the g20 is all
about how do we get people to work
together being in the banking business
there's a lot of notoriety around that
these days it's a global business it's
not a regional business it's a global
business we have a product virtual
wallet that's an online product you can
use ATMs anywhere in the world you get
notified when you're going to have an
overdraft on your cell phone I see a lot
of young people here we've opened that
account we have hundred we have a
hundred thousand users in a matter of
months it's a global business and
there's nothing that used to be more
regional more
than banking nothing but the world has
changed and that's what today is about I
think it's it's a wonderful opportunity
to work with the Atlantic Council here
so a group that comes together and
thinks deep thoughts about these deep
things and stimulate dialogue on some of
these international issues and to try
and build consensus now we know there is
no such thing as total consensus but
similar thought processes processes in
order to partner toward the common
toward the common good and I think this
conference is exactly exactly that
you'll be hearing there will be a full
report from this it'll be coming out and
the ww CMU edu and I think all of you
will enjoy reading it I'd like to
acknowledge two people dr. Kieran
Skinner where's dr. Skinner hello and
Alexei montserrat for their efforts and
putting this together if you two could
stand please and the hydroscooter your
arteries day thank you very much for you
now with that I'm going to turn this
over to the person who actually runs
this whole thing the president the CEO
of the Atlantic Council this is an
individual that has extraordinary
extraordinary experience spending over a
quarter of a century with the wall
street journal these he's seen that many
of these partnerships come and go so
with that let me turn it over to Fred
Kemp president CEO of the Atlantic
Council Fred
in the great history of such events gyms
the introducer of the introducer and i'm
going to introduce ambassador Rooney but
I also make a couple of remarks the gym
thanks very much for that this is a
crucial time that we all come together
it is an inflection point and like
inflection points in history you know
you've had a crisis you know you've had
a crisis of has brought you to the point
of critical decisions of many respects
under time pressures where you don't get
everything exactly right but the
question is where do you come out in the
other end as a long time wall street
journal editor and correspondent I like
images and so one image we've played
with and I did this with President Cohen
in the forward of the very good book of
articles and writings that you'll see
and you'll you'll you'll have here is a
ship a ship that almost sunk but we now
have it afloat again and we think that
we think it's going pretty much now in a
better direction but we have to we have
to give it the right direction we it has
to be steering the right way we have
some wind at our backs but we have to
but we're still going to get through
some choppy waters so that's sort of
nice but the one I like better was given
to me by a very senior US official in
off-the-record basis where he said we've
fallen down a mountain we've got broken
bones we're bleeding and we've hit rock
bottom and we're just grateful to be
alive and then we see some green sprouts
underneath us we see some flowers coming
out and then we look to the side and we
see it's actually all fog and cloud to
the side we're actually not sure we're
at the bottom of the mountain and so at
the same time that we're climbing back
up trying to make sure that we're
unstable ground we also have to make
sure that we don't fall bet down a lot
more mountain and hit be hit by another
crisis so that's that's a nice image for
I think where we are right now we think
we've hit some sort of bottom but we
don't really know whether we're going to
push down further but in the meantime we
have to build that bottom that we have
so it's much more stable and so that
when we climb we're going to do it in a
much more sustainable way I am the
president of the Atlantic Council I'm
pleased to be here for this timely
important event what the Atlantic
Council does and has been doing for 48
years is we've been working to promote
and to support the transatlantic
relationship but our new mission is
renewing that relationship because we
think the relationships in need of
renewal for the 21st century global
challenges if you're looking at the
global economy if you're looking at the
problems around the world they won't be
solved by us European closer cooperation
coordination but us European
coordination cooperation will be a
precondition for solving almost all of
those problems the Atlantic Council has
been known for its work on security
issues on NATO on hard security issues
but we've expanded a great deal now into
business and economic issues by
launching our global business and
economics program Alexa montserrat was
introduced this really has been his work
together with Chiron and Carnegie Mellon
and we have established a strong
presence on g20 and financial crisis
issues we've worked along to along side
two major institutions chatham house in
london and carnegie mellon university to
assemble around the two g20 last two g20
conferences the foremost thinkers and
business leaders in advances of these
summits to address the crucial issues
raised by the dangers to the world
financial system the publication that we
released two weeks ago for this summit
and for this meeting you'll hear many of
the writers from that publication
speaking here today and other
distinguished business leaders such as
Steve Forbes and and what I found in
Washington is people are running so
quickly just to attend to the daily
problems they have to attend to that the
idea is coming from the outs
if properly infiltrated and if strong
enough really do have a great influence
on what decisions get make made you'll
hear a lot today about global growth
you'll hear a lot about how do we create
in a more balanced and more sustainable
way coincidentally that's also where
President Obama is now pushing we landed
on that approach last summer because we
thought what that was the way it had to
go and and and it's always nice to be
able to take credit for presidential
policy I'm not sure we can quite say
that but I think we did predict where
where matters now have to go let me
sincerely thank Carnegie Mellon
University President Cohen Jim roar and
the board of trustees and professor
Chiron Skinner for their excellent
partnership we hope to do more with you
in the future let me also thank the US
Chamber of Commerce Gary littman is here
from the chamber and Myron brilliant
Arthur at cop who I'd like to thank for
their strong intellectual and financial
support but also in an ongoing way we've
done partnership and work together with
the US Chamber and thanks to all the
panelists and authors finally I'll just
say this is a crucial moment there are
some good signs two-point-seven percent
rise and retail sales first time we've
been in that position for three years
household wealth has risen by three
trillion dollars in the first quarter
that's the biggest growth since 2007
unemployment still pretty worrisome
thing but we're seeing certain trends
and unemployment that are looking a
little bit better so there are there are
some good signs but now the g20 has to
face a difficult task of building a
platform for reliable and balanced
growth growth that spreads the benefits
of globalization broadly and deeply we
have to learn the lessons of the crisis
we went through but we also have to be
careful not to learn the wrong lessons
Stephen Harper the Canadian Prime
Minister was in Washington last week and
he was warning the administration
against protectionism he was warning
against some of the Buy America
approaches that are sneaking into
legislation if the u.s. goes
protectionists you can assure yourself
that the rest of the world will
and if the US doesn't go in that
direction you can assure yourself that
we have much better chance that we can
also avoid the worst side of
protectionism or we have a better chance
of avoiding the worst sides of
protectionism elsewhere so finally we've
put together this conference to
formulate the way forward that we think
would be best for the g20 in making this
vision a reality learning the right
lessons from this crisis and not the
wrong lessons instead of just focusing
on technocratic efforts to prevent the
last crisis we're looking forward to
identify what's needed to foster the
emergence of a new 21st century economy
that will be less vulnerable to shocks
so now I'm going to move to the most
important part of this evening or this
evening this morning and that's
ambassador Rooney I did commiserate with
him last evening on the fact that his
Pittsburgh Steelers didn't give him the
best welcome on Sunday and being
European I've been practicing my soccer
kick and I think I can give the
Pittsburgh Steelers a little bit of help
against Cincinnati the sunday if you you
feel you need a different place kicker
but to start off on this thing to start
off I want to say that introducing
ambassador Rooney in Pittsburgh is a
little bit like introducing Caesar in
Rome but it is my duty after growing up
in Pittsburgh and graduating from
duquesne university ambassador Rooney
began working for the Steelers his dad's
team in 1960 I learned a lot last night
about the beginnings of this team in
1933 when there were blue laws where you
couldn't play on Sunday that had to be
dealt with so from that point on to now
you and your family have dealt with all
the challenges of running one of the
most extraordinary businesses and and
sporting teams in the world you took
over as president and sit 1975
successfully managing the franchise
until two thousand three and under your
tenure the steelers have won six of
seven Super Bowls in which they've
played for your outstanding storage of
the team and for your great
contributions to the National Football
League
in august of two thousand you joined
your father in the NFL Hall of Fame and
I believe you're only the second father
and son tandem to be given that honor
outside of your work with the NFL you've
also been very well known in Ireland for
extensive philanthropy work as one of
the founders of the American Ireland
funds and its principal funder of the
rooney prize in Irish literature because
of your dedication to promoting peace
culture and charity in Ireland
ambassador Rooney was named US
ambassador to Ireland in July of 2009 I
also think it's important that this man
of great integrity and wisdom and a man
who stayed relatively clear of politics
through most of his life saw in
candidate Obama something he wanted to
put his weight behind this of course
followed the visionary introduction of
the rooney rule in the NFL so you've led
a life of enormous integrity enormous
wisdom enormous success you bring you
bring all the qualities of person who
knows how to get things done but also
knows what he wants to get done so
Ireland in many ways that the country
you've gone to now represents a
microcosm of the financial crisis the
economy had run away grow six percent
annual growth from 1994 2007 it was one
of the great economic stories on earth
and then of course it got hit harder
than many countries by the financial
crisis and is trying to turn to these
same towns to come back as with the
global economy as a whole Ireland must
now learn learn the right lessons from
the crisis keeping what worked in
reforming what didn't I am greatly
looking forward to hearing ambassador
Rooney's thoughts on where the Irish
find themselves and where they plan to
go and the lessons that this can teach
about a new global growth and I cannot
avoid a football metaphor as I pass to
you with the certainty that this will
not be intercepted thank you
Thank You Fred I really want to thank
thread Kemp and Jared Cohen co-host of
the conference for inviting me to speak
this morning on this time for this
timely conference on the way out my wife
Patricia said make sure you speak up and
don't mumble as you usually do but but I
want to say that I am a little jet lag
so if things go a little bit of stray I
hope that Fred will come up and wake me
up the worst thing of course would be if
I put you all to sleep so I hope that
that doesn't happen for those who have
travelled to get here I'd like to
welcome I'd like to welcome you to our
home time falta as we say in Ireland we
are thrilled to host a g20 meeting I
can't think of a better place for the
world leaders to come and discuss what
to do about the global economy
pittsburgh has seen its ups and downs it
was known for steel manufacturing
industries the steel manufacturing
stopped and jobs were scarce and the
people and companies left and the city
was in decline the city officials as Jim
talked a little bit earlier and the
community leaders made good decisions
and now Pittsburgh is doing well again
in healthcare education technology
special manufacturing and service we can
learn from pizza from the Pittsburgh
experience which is mirrored the changes
in the US economy as it moved from
manufacturing to service I would like to
start this morning by looking briefly at
the global economy and the challenges
facing the world leaders who are
gathered here for the g20 then I'd like
to tell you about Ireland my home for a
while regardless of the makeup of its
economy since the end of World War two
the United States has been the main
driver of the economic growth globally
even today America counts for depending
on how you measure it between 20 and 25
percent of the world's output in the
last 20 to 30 years the increased rate
of globalization has benefited our
country greatly however these benefits
have not only been felt in the US but
many other countries have seen their
economies boosted by the increased trade
and investment for example just in the
past 10 years the economies of the BRIC
countries Brazil Russia India and China
have grown rapidly that said their lower
GDP per capita shows that they still
have room to grow the most important
thing for each in every country
including the u.s. is to develop a
balanced economy limit create
sustainable growth and provides equal
opportunity to its citizens and that
brings us to why we are here to begin to
shape the global economy and financial
systems following the crisis at the g20
leaders meeting last April the countries
agreed to do whatever it took to support
recovery and strengthen financial
supervision and regulation so that a
Christ crisis of the current magnitude
does not recur the Pittsburgh meaning is
an ideal opportunity to build on the
April meeting and adopt policies to move
forward on several fronts including
prioritized jobs and train people for
the 21st century economy further
strengthen the global financial systems
support initial initiatives on food
security financial access and energy in
the world's poorest countries set the
contours of a finance a financing
framework to combat climate change and
strengthen our energy security by
increasing market transparent
transparencies fortunately since April
clear progress has been made the g20
output has increased in the second
quarter of 200
9 and growth will continue in the second
half of that year for 2010 the
International Monetary Fund IMF expects
collective g20 growth of three-point-two
percent compared to an overall
contraction of 1.1 percent in 2009
despite these positive signs we can't
relax consumers won't be spending much
because unemployment is still rising
nobody's going to spend if they fear
they're losing their jobs the IMF noted
that the greatest risk is a stalled
recovery we need to continue using all
the policy tools fiscal monetary and
financial to make sure this doesn't
happen preliminary withdrawal or
withdrawing support risk a return to
recessionary conditions and the
instability in the financial market that
said there will come to a point where
recovery is sustainable then the g20
countries will need to unwind the
extraordinary support measures put in
place to overcome the crisis as recovery
is established we need to have in place
a new framework that will support
healthy and vibrant global economy we
hope to reach agreement on such a
framework in Pittsburgh the impact of
the crisis on workers has been
particularly severe as growth returns we
need to do everything we can to ensure
that employment does as well the g20
should commit to implementing recovery
plans that prioritize job growth income
support for the unemployed and quick
regaining of employment substantial
progress has been made and the
commitments made in Washington and
London to improve financial supervision
and regulation in London we reached
consensus on a global framework to
reform and we can point to many
accomplishments including the expanded
scope of regulation to include
previously under-regulated institution
markets and products strengthen
prudential oversight and enhanced
regulation through higher capital
requirements on risky assets and
off-balance sheet items improve risk
management strengthen financial
integrity by bolstering international
standards in three areas tax information
exchange any anti money laundering to
combat the financing of terrorism and
prudential oversight through expanded
use of peer pressure mechanisms which
measure and promote compliance with the
standards our challenge now is to put
the framework in place the challenges
posed by the crisis have highlighted the
need to improve our multilateral
cooperation in order to further promote
global financial stability foster
sustainable development and lift the
lives of the poorest from poverty
modernizing the international financial
institutions in global development
networks will be essential I would like
to add here that President Obama has
energized world leaders to make the
commitment to bring global financial
stability to the entire world in order
to guarantee an economic sustainable of
the coming decades the Irish tea shock
may not have all the answers and
President Obama doesn't either but the
point is that both are working to solve
problems we love our democratic freedoms
in order to keep them and make things
better we have to work at it and that's
what I know the countries represented in
Pittsburgh will do now to Ireland
Ireland is a small country about the
size of our Pennsylvania even though
Ireland is not a g20 country it has
achieved much over the last 20 years
some say the main export of Ireland
until the 1980s was people that changed
when the Irish people from all walks of
life said enough and reached a consensus
of what to do about
the economy with those good decisions
Ireland caught up to and passed its
European neighbours in terms of living
standards a critical component of
Ireland's resurgent has been its
openness to foreign direct investment in
trade irish policymakers saw that
Ireland's future dependent on the
openness and the country clearly reap
braked reaped the rewards from this
decision as shown by the steep economic
downturn in Ireland small countries are
greatly affected by international
economic conditions however because the
world's economy is so interconnected it
works the other way too if a small
country economy collapses the effects
are felt well beyond its borders so it
behooves the larger economics to remain
engaged in the with countries such as
Ireland and offer support as needed
however Ireland is not waiting for
others to make decisions first the
government has taken many steps to put
the economy right including setting up
the national asset management agency
nema to take property loans off the
books of the banks in hope that this
will enable the banks to begin lending
again in a speech by former Irish
President Mary Robinson she said the
challenge that Ireland faces demands a
comprehensive vision of what sort of
society the country wants she said that
the shape a vision of how Ireland hopes
to develop as a society we need to
listen to everyone who has something to
contribute yes the business sector and
the financial experts but also the
social entrepreneurs and innovators and
the teachers who educate our children
and those who have been marginalized in
the past I mentioned our speech not just
because I personally agree with her but
also because it includes some lessons
for those assembled here and later in
the week of the g20 specifically that we
have a better chance of building a
sustainable global we call
if we listen to everyone who has a state
Ireland did it once with great success
and I am convinced they will do it again
I'm equally convinced that the
representatives of the g20 countries
will make the right decisions this past
weekend the Irish government sponsored
the farm Lee conference and they invited
Irish people from all over the globe at
the initial session Greg Barrett past
CEO of Intel was most critical of
Ireland regarding education especially
for the lack of engineers and science
being grad being graduated from
ireland's universities he also included
the United States for lack of
engineering graduate graduates now you
would know much more about that than I I
agree we should graduate more engineers
and scientists it's important for our
competition but I believe we must
upgrade the entire curriculum to support
a student's ability to think there is
much down time instead we could enhance
the focus for the philosophies ethics
literature history language along with
math physics and science and chemistry
Patricia my wife was a professor at
robert morris university four of our
children were or are teachers one of our
daughters is a lawyer but she was not
satisfied with the education that her
children were receiving and went back to
school and became a teacher there are
many things we do but the most important
contribution we make is to education it
bothers me and I'm sure many of you
whenever there are economic problems the
first thing the politicians want to
consider is cutting the education budget
that is a small minded approach Ireland
has real opportunities to be a world
leader in areas of renewable energy
Ireland has some of the best wind
biomass and ocean energy in the world
and given the government's commitment to
invest in research and development it
could soon become an ideal site for
innovation in this sector targeting
renewable energy
would kill three birds with one stone it
would assist Ireland in reducing its
carbon emissions improve its energy
security and importantly build a new
domestic industry this is just another
area in which the u.s. and Ireland could
work together cooperatively I leave you
here again I could say much more about
Ireland a wonderful country with bright
people and excellent leadership we can
use Ireland as a role model and find it
as a positive factor thank you for
listening and I hope that these thoughts
will set the stage for the Pittsburgh
summit I hope Pittsburgh will not only
be the positive turning point for the
economy but will be known as the place
we came together and made a better life
for all slinte god bless
you